the latest Media Matters hit job you
know because apparently we aren't
providing them enough fodder just based
on what we say every day on all of our
shows now they're going back and they're
combing through media matters is our
entire like catalog of old videos and
um Ariel Drennen who's a male employee
at Media Matters found a video from a
bit that all of the hosts filmed a
couple of years ago on Valentine's Day
and I forgot that this existed that we
even did this but
um the basic gist is that our wives
were asked questions about us and then
we were asked the same questions and
whoever's answers lined up the best with
what the wife said won and uh I don't I
think I think Drew won this this uh he's
been married the longest it really was
not fair
um anyway Drennan and a bunch of
leftists who reacted this clip were
especially offended by uh and by the way
you
they were
I know as soon as they saw that this
clip existed that we did some kind of
Valentine's Day you know bit fake game
show thing involving you know talking
about our relationships with our wives
as soon as they saw that they knew that
they had hit a jackpot because they knew
that they're automatically going to be
able to find something offensive like
it's impossible in their Twisted
worldview it's impossible for a straight
male to say anything about his
relationship with his wife that won't
automatically be offensive and so
um they really had their pick of the
litter on this one and uh this is what
they this is what they decided was
offensive let's watch it
all right Matt uh it's kind of a trick
question because I I hate them both
equally so I but I guess I would say
I would rather do the dishes but I'd
prefer if she just did both of the
things Michael to you dishes it's no
question I'm not sure in our entire
marriage if I've ever done a full load
of laundry so I think I have that one I
like it all right Drew well this is a
trick question because I have not done
anything around the house for over 40
years I've been a completely useless but
it's it's clear that if I had to choose
it would be it would have to be dishes
because she was just out of town for a
month and I actually called her up and
said how do you do laundry so I think
this is the only thing I know how to do
all right to the answers Ben you
answered dishes Mrs Shapiro said I'm not
sure Ben knows how to do laundry so I'll
go with the dishes which he does quite
often and she threw in a little thanks
hun Matt you answered
I hate them both but dishes your wife
said dishes and she also threw in he
doesn't know how to do the laundry again
being thrown under the bus true Michael
you answer dishes your wife said neither
but if there was a gun to his head he
would choose dishes
and Drew finally you answered I don't do
anything but the dishes if I had to and
your wife put again in all caps here
very forceful answer since he doesn't
know how to do laundry as we learned
when I was out of town for several weeks
I'm guessing it's the dishes
you caught us you caught us we're uh we
are we are normal people and men who are
in normal happy marriages and we have a
sense of humor and our wives do too
you caught us you caught us red-handed
you caught us red-handed being in
healthy well-adjusted normal marriages
where we have a sense of humor about
things caught us I don't know what to
say I mean we we and and I know uh a
sense of humor and a happy marriage are
two things that nobody at Media Matters
has ever had or will ever have and so
for them this is like shocking stuff
um
and and just you know like some of what
you saw there I know I have to kind of
break it down for uh you freaks um so a
lot of what you just saw there it's
called Uh and uh it's a it's called a
joke okay and joke's very interesting
where it said j-o-k is how you spell it
and
um so this is this is what's this is
what's called it's like just being kind
of humorous and laughing about something
um
do I know how to do the laundry
technically
of course I do like you just you throw
the stuff in and you hit the button it's
not that hard you put the detergent in
of course we know how to do that now as
far as sorting the laundry by color or
whatever and all that kind of stuff or
checking the labels on all the dish all
the all the individual you know items of
clothing to see what setting to put it
on
I'm not going to do that do I know how
to do it can I read the label physically
and I can but I'm not going to do that
so I take it's more of a Kamikaze
approach if if ever my wife makes the
mistake of
you know putting me anywhere near the
laundry I'm going to take a more
Kamikaze approach of just you know it's
it's Kamikaze style throw it all in
there and whatever happens happens
um in fact just recently I did a load of
laundry and everything came out pink and
my point was
it's kind of a fun game you know you
just throw stuff in you don't know
what's going to happen you don't know
what color it's going to come out you
don't know how how what size the things
will be when they come out of the
laundry uh you never know it's a lot of
fun it's kind of like a game
um my wife doesn't appreciate that
approach as much so I don't do much of
the laundry
and that's fine that's how you you know
this is this is a thing people do in
marriages and really it's like in normal
life where you're kind it's kind of
Hyperbole and but it's it's sort of not
and you're joking around there's a grain
of truth to it uh again that's like a
it's
being a normal human that's stuff that
comes with that it's that it comes with
that territory
but you see just how angry
these people are at normalcy they really
hate it which is why you know
they always it's it's it's it's it's
it's always so easy to predict ahead of
time
what bits and what things people in
Media Matters are going to take and try
to blow up and make a big thing about
because it's always I always know
at the end of every show I can look back
and say what are the most normal Common
Sense things I said today of all the
things I said what were the most normal
and Common Sense things and it's always
going to be those things that they are
going to post and say you can't believe
what Matt Walsh said this time
because they really hate normalcy and
they don't and they've never experienced
it and they don't understand it and uh
and that's all fine
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block uh you can become a member today
and use code walls to check out for two
months for you on all annual plans hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]